حسنًا وزيرة الخارجية الأردنية إيمان
سفاري أه تنضم إلي الآن من أمان أه
شكرًا لانضمامك إلينا لقد رأينا للتو
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي مع أه رئيس
الوزراء الذي كان بعد أن التقى سيدي
بأه الملك عبد الله في وقت سابق وكنت
في ذلك الاجتماع  ما تمت مناقشته
وبصراحة أنت تعرف كيف كانت
أجواء الاجتماع ما هو
واقعي في هذه
المرحلة أه مساء الخير سادسا كما قلت لجنة الأوراق المالية والبورصة بلانكين
كانت هنا التقيت بجلالته
التقيت بهم أيضًا أه من الواضح أن
التركيز هو كيف  نخرج من هذا
الكابوس الذي اجتاح غزة وأه
المنطقة بأكملها أه كيف نخفف التصعيد
كيف نضمن
وصول الإمدادات الإنسانية إلى أه مئات الآلاف
من الأشخاص في غزة الذين ليس لديهم إمكانية
الوصول إلى الغذاء والمأوى المائي وإلى حد
كبير كيف  هل نخرج من
دائرة العنف الخطيرة للغاية والتي
أثبت الزمن مرارا وتكرارا أنها لن تؤدي إلا إلى
تفاقم الأمور أه علينا أن نفكر في
كيفية إنهاء هذا
التصعيد الخطير ولكننا أيضا كيف
نتأكد من أننا نصل إلى  النقطة التي يمكننا من خلالها
تجنب حدوث ذلك مرة أخرى، وهذا ما
بذلناه من جهد لسنوات وأعتقد
الآن أنه من الواضح للجميع أن
العنف لن يؤدي إلا إلى المزيد من العنف، فالحرب
ليست هي الحل، فلنتعامل مع
الآن، أوقف هذه الكارثة مرة أخرى، فكر في
اليوم
التالي ويجب أن أقول إنك تعرف يا
وزير الخارجية أنت وأنا نتحدث بشكل منتظم وقد تم
تحذيرك من
التصعيد المثير للقلق في أعمال
العنف خلال الأشهر الماضية
على مدى السنوات الماضية وقد حذرت
من أننا قد نواجه نوعا من
الكارثة ويبدو أننا على
حافة ذلك أريد أن أتحدث عن
التصعيد في المنطقة أو
التصعيد المحتمل أه للحظات
لنبدأ على وجه التحديد ب
غزة وماذا سيحدث بعد ذلك
قالت وزارة الخارجية أن أنتوني بلينكن
يمارس الضغط على إسرائيل أه لإنشاء
مناطق آمنة للمدنيين ما الذي تفهمه يتم
عمله
لمنع الأذى عن المدنيين في حالة
بدء هذا الغزو البري والمزيد من الهجمات الجوية
أه بالفعل أه  لممارسة
ضغوط كبيرة ضغوط أكبر
على المدنيين في
غزة بيكي كما قلت ليس فقط
أننا حذرنا من مثل هذه
اللحظة الرهيبة أه التي تجتاح المنطقة ولكن أه كما
تعلم أه جلالته كان يعمل على
مدار الساعة لتجنب  هذه أه هذه
اللحظة للأسف جهودنا
لم تصل بنا إلى النقطة التي كنا
سنصل إليها ونحن حيث نحن ودعني
أبدأ أولاً بأه إعادة
التأكيد على
الموقف الأردني القديم الذي
ندينه  قتل المدنيين من
الطرفين أن كل حياة مهمة سواء كانت
فلسطينية أو إسرائيلية وأن أه كلما
خسرنا المزيد من الأرواح كلما أصبح من الصعب
أه الابتعاد عن هذا
مرة أخرى أه أه الهاوية التي كنا فيها
دفعت اه مرة أخرى الأولوية
الآن هم 2.3 مليون شخص في غزة
الأبرياء نساء أطفال أطفال أه
لا يمكن أن نوقع بهم مرة أخرى هم
بالفعل ضحايا لظروف تم
دفعهم إليها مرة أخرى لذا
الأولوية الآن للحصول على أه فورية أه
الإمدادات الإنسانية و  عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمنطقة الآمنة أه علينا أن نكون
حذرين للغاية كذلك يجب أن نكون داخل غزة لا
يمكن أن يكون لدينا نزوح سكان أه لا
يمكن أن يكون لدينا نقل سكان أه
وعلينا التأكد من أنه الآن
توقف التهدئة حتى
تعمل الإمدادات الإنسانية  على ممر إنساني
لدخول الإمدادات أه أه أوقفوا
القتال ثم ابدأوا العمل
أه لحركتنا الكبيرة كدعاة سلام
وحركتنا الكبيرة كدعاة سلام
لمواجهة التحرك الذي فرض
علينا هو وزير الخارجية لذلك  دعونا نتحدث
دعونا نتحدث عن هاتين المسألتين نعم دعونا
نتحدث عن هاتين المسألتين
إدخال المساعدات الإنسانية وإجلاء
مواطني غزة أه الآن
يقال لهم الإخلاء إلى جنوب
غزة في الوقت الحاضر ما تقوله
هو أن الأردن لا يريد أن يرى
إجلاء المواطنين من
غزة
صحيح
تماما ومرة ​​أخرى بيكي
1.2 مليون شخص في شمال غزة أين
ستجليهم إلى أه
أين سيذهبون أه مرة أخرى مصر دعني
أتحدث
عن نعم دعني أفهم
ذلك  كيف ستدخل المساعدات ومن
سيقدم تلك
المساعدات نحن جميعا نعمل على تقديم المساعدات أه
نحن نتحدث مع مصر أه إسرائيل يجب أن
تسمح بدخول المساعدات أه لقد أرسلنا بالفعل
شحنة إلى أه أه  إلى مصر فقط
في حالة أه لنكون جاهزين عندما تكون
الحدود مفتوحة نحن
نعمل أيضًا على توصيل أه أه كبير للأردن
أيضًا أه للحصول على المساعدات عبر
الضفة الغربية وإلى غزة عندما
تأتي اللحظة المناسبة  وعندما
يتوقف القتال أه هذا أمر
حتمي ننظر أيضًا إلى أونا
واسمحوا لي أن أؤكد على
الدور المهم الذي تلعبه أونا لقد فقدت أونا
بالفعل 12 شخصًا في صراع
غزة أثناء محاولتهم توفير الغذاء
والماء ل  أكثر من 200.000 شخص
غمروا مدارسها وملاجئها أه. لقد
طلبنا بالأمس من الحكومة
التبرع لأندروا من أجل غزة، وعرضنا
4.5 مليون دولار، ونحتاج من الجميع أن
يأتوا ويساعدوا أندا لأنه لا أحد يستطيع أن
يفعل ما يفعله هناك، دعوني
قبل أن نبدأ  تحدث عن القلق
من التصعيد في المنطقة وقد
رأيت احتجاجات في الأردن أه اليوم وخلال
أه الأيام الماضية وأريد أن
أتحدث عن مدى قلقك
بشأن ما تراه في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
قبل أن نفعل ذلك أنا فقط  أريد أن أكون
واضحا تماما بشأن هذا أه كما تعلم لقد
التقى الملك عبد الله أه جلالة الملك مع أنتوني بلينكن اليوم وما
تخبرني به هو أنه لا توجد
تفاصيل محددة حتى الآن بشأن
إجلاء مواطني غزة ولكن الأردن
يريد أن يرى  أولئك الذين تم إيواؤهم داخل
غزة ليسوا أم لا يغادرون غزة وأنت
تقول أن هناك حاجة ولكن لم يتم
إنشاء ممر للمساعدات الإنسانية
إلى غزة بعد، صحيح صحيح، صحيح،
دعونا نتحدث
عما يحدث في جميع أنحاء المنطقة،
فنحن نشهد حقًا أه نشهد
تدفقًا  الغضب في الكثير من أنحاء
العالم العربي بما في ذلك في بلدك سيدي،
ما مدى قلقك بشأن
انتشار العنف في هذه المرحلة؟
أعني مرة أخرى أننا قلقون للغاية
بشأن انتشار هذا الصراع، أه
الأولوية القصوى بالنسبة لنا هي الضفة الغربية ثم
لدينا  لبنان أه لأنه إذا كان
الصراع إذا كان مستوى العنف
والحرب نراها يمتد إلى تلك
الأراضي فسوف تبتلع المنطقة كلها أه
رد الفعل الشعبي
سيكون أكثر عدوانية مرة أخرى أه
أه المدنيون مدنيون من
الجانبين  لكن الآن الصور التي
تخرج من غزة أه ليست فقط هي التي تكسر
قلوب الجميع كما فعلت
الصور السابقة أه ولكن مرة أخرى
تدفع نحو الغضب الذي هو
واضح سوف يتجلى بشكل
أكبر ونحاول  للتأكد من أن
الناس لديهم الحق في التعبير عن
أنفسهم ولكن أيضًا العمل على
مدار الساعة للتأكد من أننا نجد
اختراقًا في في في تخفيف التصعيد
و و و منع أه هذا
الوضع الرهيب من الامتداد إلى
أه أه الضفة الغربية  و و لبنان
أيضاً